- Hey, we're the Fast Food Friends
and today we're going to be trying
Chef Gordon Ramsay's
airfryer steak recipe.
- All right, so we got aleppo pepper,
and then we got coffee grounds,
this nice ribeye steak.
- I'm going to mix
together the aleppo pepper
and the coffee, now
we're just making a rub,
so I'm going to put equal parts
coffee and pepper in there.
- How spicy is it?
Oh, bet.
- He says to put the
rub on the plate first,
so that's what I'm gonna do.
- Massage the meat there.
A little shiatsu going.
- Make sure you get all the edges.
Chef Ramsay says to make sure
to preheat your airfryer to
390 for at least three minutes,
You're gonna put it in, and let it cook
for 8 to 10 minutes.
- It's only been a couple of minutes since
I put it in the airfryer
but already it smelling like
coffee and pepper up in here.
- I want to say, I don't
know if you hear this
but it's sizzling and I'm getting hungry.
- That sizzle, baby.
- Oh my goodness gracious, look at that.
- Holy guacamole! Look at this steak!
- Are we kidding?
Look at that.
That's not what I was expecting.
Is that what you were expecting?
- Just going to transfer
it to our cutting board
and every chef knows
you let your steak rest
for at least 10 minutes.
So I'm just going to put this whole foil
over it so it doesn't get too cold.
And then we'll come back
in about 10 minutes and let it rest.
- I'm gonna cut in and see what it looks
like.
Okay, nice and soft.
I wanted a little bit of pink.
- Wow, wow, wow,
Look at this steak.
This is insane.
- I like my things to medium rare.
This looks a little bit more cooked.
- Here we go.
Look at that bad boy.
First bite.
(jazzy music)
- Whoa!
- Damn, Gordan Ramsay!
- I am pleased.
- It has a really good card page.
- It is very, very good.
Honestly, I feel like
mine came out slightly
overcooked.
- It's not as like tender as a, you know,
medium, medium rare steak.
This thing is mega flavorful.
The pepper and the coffee go perfectly.
- It gives it like more
of an earthy taste.
- This was two steps.
Put seasoning on steak,
put steak in airfryer.
That's all you got to do.
This is insane.
- I do miss a little bit
of the salt content that I
would usually have
if I seasoned it the way I typically do.
That being said, I can't stop eating it.
- I think overall,
this was really good, very delicious
- I'm gonna be airfrying
steaks all the time now.
That's kind of become a regular thing.
It's Gordon Ramsay.
So I feel like we should have known
that it was going to be pretty good
- Gordan Ramsay. I think you a baddie.
- I'm going to go
ahead and give my steak a 8 out of 10.
- This is easily a score of 9.5 out of 10.
If this was medium rare?
- Y'all try it at home,
let us know in the
comments what you think.
I just want to air fry everything now.
(funky music)